welcome to mom Bryce's chef competition
we're a professional chef in a mom cook
head-to-head preparing the best dish
possible with one secret ingredient our
first competitor is Hannah Williams I'm
Hannah I am a mother too I have a
three-year-old and a 10 month old and
I'm a home cook
I've been cooking my whole life but I've
never taken a cooking class I used to
check out recipe book from the library
and bookmark them and do my nighttime
reading so I'm hoping that that helps me
out in this competition I really want to
win today because I want to make my kids
proud when I left the house this morning
my three-year-old told me that I was a
very good cookie and I think that men
cook he might have just meant cookie but
if I can come home and tell him that I
took something delicious he's gonna be
so proud of me and competing against
Hannah is professional chef Steven frets
it's look guys I'm chef Steven frets
from our executive chef managing partner
of the church key here in Los Angeles
California
I've been cooking something like 21
years I kind of come from a higher-end
backgrounds we kind of take on the world
cuisine which we bring to America and
call it modern American cuisine I have
nine nieces and nephews I feel like I
have some sort of ability to cook for
children what would winning mom versus
chef mean to me well you know bragging
rights with my three older sisters right
welcome Hannah chef Steven today we're
gonna be competing to make the tastiest
dish featuring one secret ingredient let
me introduce you to our panels judges hi
I'm Kai and I'm CIA
like playing my drums I'm Justin and I'm
nine years old and I like to do active
and your final judge is me I'm Andrew 25
years old and they're like race cars so
I think it's time to find out what the
secret ingredient is so chefs whatever
you cook today has to incorporate this
secret ingredient it is not going to be
easy Justin will you do the honors
please you guys know what this is
also course poop so chefs today your
secret ingredient is spinach
I was hoping not to get something green
like broccoli or spinach or something
like that
Anna how do you feel that spinach I've
never met a kid who likes it oh gosh I
don't work well Jesse yeah 30 minutes to
cook your food and your time starts now
spinach is one of the hardest things to
get into a child so I'm thinking how can
I incorporate this green color my mind
immediately goes to one of my son's
obsessions which is Minecraft so I'm
gonna make green creeper minecraft can
cakes with an egg frittata that is also
green and I'm going to turn that into a
pixelated tree with a bacon trunk I've
never put spinach in the kid dish
generally at the restaurant the big faux
pas is putting anything green on the
dish so what I think I'm gonna do is I
think I'm gonna go with something cheesy
like a cheesy alfredo sauce kids love
cheesy they love pasta and I think it's
a good way to hide the the spinach right
so I get my eggs in I get about a cup of
spinach and I get a little bit of milk
this is gonna be for the frittata and I
blend the crud out of it until you can't
really see this
hoping that I didn't over blend it and
this foam goes down if it doesn't I'm
just gonna have to scrap this whole idea
I'll probably just start off with
sauteing the onions and some garlic or
no kids like garlic but they're about to
get some reduce that down with a little
bit of chicken stock I think I found
some cream and we'll just mount that
with some cheese cut it with some acid
from some lemon and then hopefully we'll
be able to disguise the spinach the way
we need to for the kids all right I'm
gonna have a drink of water
so the pancakes come off taste them it's
a really overpowering taste of spinach
and it's not supposed to taste that way
and I'm hoping that the judges are not
gonna notice hey chefs
yeah 15 minutes left so hurry up how
does that taste
so what's your favorite food possible
start menu buckle I think my favorite
food is steak I love steak so I'm
looking over at Hannah and I noticed
like she has kids and she understands
the mindset of kids and she's putting
together this puzzle of a dish I thought
to myself this is actually you know
really smart I hope that they can
translate as as a tree trunk because
this is all banking on the fact that
these kids know what minecraft is now
for the face on this pancake I usually
use blueberries to make a face I go to
the pantry on omelet cm so I grab the
chocolate chips they're super hard I
hope that the pancake is warm enough to
melt it a little bit I'm just kind of
all over the place at this point
but it's too late to change my mind you
know as I'm making my dish I do I do
think that the kids are gonna enjoy my
dish I'm feeling fairly confident that I
might have this under control
what's up guy way making I'm making a
pasta alfredo sauce with bacon we're
gonna have spinach I knew a little bit
of lemon I smell bacon over there yeah
right I love bacon I put bacon and
everything thank you welcome hey Hannah
hey how's it going I'm not quite sure
what boys
this age are into but I've heard a lot
about Minecraft you know I don't really
know that much about Minecraft so feel
like you should have catered towards my
likes a little more I feel like you can
appreciate theme we'll see if it works
hey [ __ ] you have five minutes left good
boy
better start plating start wrapping up
well I'm cooking I'm thinking about my
kids I'm thinking about how much they
look up to me and I'm hoping still that
I can make them proud but seeing how
things are going I'm not feeling so good
about my tongue constantly I'm stirring
the sauce to make sure it doesn't burn
right on the hot plates
sometimes that direct contact can can
burn your cheese smelling chef Stephan
food is really putting a damper on
everything so at this point whatever it
is however it looks however it tastes I
just want it to get to the plate 5 4 3 2
1
okay stop working chefs the competition
is over you'll now judge your dishes hmm
kind of KP describe your dish what I
made for you the Minecraft breakfast
when I think of spinach I think of that
bright green color and when I think of
bright green I think of the creeper from
Minecraft because my son is obsessed
with it do you guys know what minecraft
is thank you I had the game yes so you
have a green creeper pancake with
chocolate chip face and a green egg and
bacon tree that's also like the trees
from the game and I don't know what kind
of toppings you guys like on your
pancakes so I have some melted butter
and syrup and I hope you enjoy it
you love eggs and not really but it's a
Racine egg
hey hey hey there's a lot of Hispanic in
there if they'd st. Greene Kim it's
really good though damn a mustache yeah
you have a little mustache there I don't
think you disguise the spinach as much
as you thought you would in the pancakes
but as like a spinach bread kind of
thing it's actually really nice I like
to bake it the only thing I didn't
really like was the chocolate chips the
chocolate and spinach is a little weird
combination Thank You Hannah
thank you just even being please tell us
about the dish I kind of went with the
the cheesy goodness of pasta so I made I
made a bacon alfredo sauce with a little
bit of garlic some onions a little bit
of lemon and then a lot of parmesan
cheese sour cream and cream and then you
have your spinach just at the end that
was folded in please enjoy what about
this spinach in there it's not as
disguised as Hannah's was I could taste
a hint of lemon and it's really good
Venki way good
it's very tasty honestly I wish this
spinach was coming through a little more
spinach is not helping the dish thanks
for everything chef and hello thanks
guys Thank You chef and Hannah we need a
moment to decide so spinach on what do
you think kids are just unpredictable
you know I'm not feeling really good
about what they thought so far I keep
thinking back I should have put less
spinach in it it's so lemon green and it
wouldn't have tasted so much like
spinach the point was to use spinach you
know that's what they gave us to you so
you know I just wanted to make it cheesy
we'll see what happens it's a tall I
feel like it's a total toss-up who do
you think did a better job I think was
steamed I think Hanna because of the
eggs I didn't really taste the vinegar
I mean y8 it just even had a little
bacon bits yeah I mean it was very tasty
which one's easy
I don't know they both had good things
yeah but they're good we'll only one can
win between the bathroom you could see a
little bit of hair sticking out of your
nose
chef Steven Hannah thank you you
prepared some amazing food today
unfortunately we can only have one
winner chef Steven your food was tasty
but Hannah I think your food was tastier
Hannah you're the first winner of mom
versus Jack congratulations I was not
expecting to win at all so I'm still
kind of a shock I think they announced
my name that I won and I just started
shaking I came here because my two sons
think that I'm a really good cook and I
wanted to prove them right I wanted to
show that I could do it so I get to go
home I had them here's this competition
ever and I thank you so much I thought
this experience was fantastic what she
did with Minecraft was really cool and
the kids really gravitated towards it
and it it kept their attention while
they were eating so guys today the mom
won you both for coming in cooking food
for us it was really amazing
Oh